لا اله الا الله
من اسعاف ابنها الذي توفي بعد اصابته بحمى
الوادي المتصدع في مدينه طانطان شرقيه
موريتانيا
فقد بدات كانها حمى عاديه لكن النزيف الذي
صاحبها جعل الحاله تزداد سوءا
الصغير التقط العدوى عن طريق حيوانات
مصابه كما اكد خاله والطاقه الطبي الذي
تابع تطورته
والله السابعه
اين جاءته اللي هو فيه اغراض كانوا كانوا
فيه الدم
تنتشروا مثل هذه الحمى الفيروسيه النزيفيه
على نطاق واسع بعد كل موسم خريف في اكثر
من محافظه الموريتانيه
ويزداد الضغط على المرافق الصحيه بسبب
الحالات المشتبه في اصابتها خصوصا بعد
اعلان وفاه عدد من المواطنين
للتوجه الى المستشفيات وتدعو الى توخي
الحذر عند العنايه بالحيوانات
الحيوان الذي فيه
حمى نزيفيه واللي عنده اعراض مشتبه يلا
يعزلوها عن القطعان الحيوان
وابلاغ
السلطات البيطريه بحالات مشتبهه بالحيوان
من اجل حمايه الانسان
ولحومها خشيه انتقال الاصابه اليهم
كما تزيد الاعباء الماليه عليهم نظرا
لحالات النفوق في الماشيه وتكاليف حجر
المخارطين والعنايه بهم
وتجوب فرق من وزاره التنميه الحيوانيه
المناطق الريفيه التي تضم المئات من مربي
الماشيه لتحسينها وتعقيم اماكن وجودها
وكذلك لاخذ عينات منها لاجراء الفحوص
والتاكد من سلامتها
[موسيقى]
تكملوا خطورته حمى الوادي المتصدع في
انتقاله الى الانسان عن طريق الذواب
بالمصابه اولى ساعات البعوضه لذلك تشهد
المرافق الصحيه حاله استنفار وتتاهب
لمحاصره بؤر الوباء للحد قدر المستطاع من
الخسائر الماديه والبشريه
الجزيره مدينه طانطان شرقي موريتانيا